keep
us well thank you all so much for being
here want Antony I'll start with you
this is for you a return to themes of
survival uh that I loved your film The
Impossible and from what I understand
you you encountered the book on which
this film is based while making that
movie can you talk a little bit about
encountering that story researching um
for the impossible when the Society of
the snow was um published in Spain and I
was shocked because I thought I knew the
story but it it's a very different book
from a life it was written 35 years
after the plane crash so you can
tell that you have the the weight the
gravitas of all the time that had
passed uh all the unanswered questions
that the survivors still have 50 years
after the the plane crash um and I
really was impressed about the spiritual
approach to the story
almost like a philosophical approach and
that made the story much bigger than
what I thought it was I gave the book to
all the head of Department I I was
reading pages to to Naomi wats and Tom
Holland during the shoot because it gave
me a a good approach to the inner life
of the characters during that situation
and I was so so so shocked so impressed
so mve that I remember that the last day
of the shoot of the impossible that was
200 and 10 I think we we bought the
rights to do this film can you talk
about the scope of the shoot because I
know this was an extensive shoot you
shot in many locations as authentically
as you could I told all the head of
departments
I wanted the actors to go through the
same Journey they went through
chronologically in the same condition so
I told Felix FZ not to use green screen
because I didn't want the actors to not
not to be distracted by that I prepared
the actors for months for this film and
and I told him that we were going to
shoot the film as if it was a
documentary so so we we gave the actors
the space to to try things unet to
explore to commit mistakes you know it's
good to go to an actor and say don't
this is not a play I prefer you to take
risk and commit mistakes that not try
things you know so it was all about
preparing the
film uh to allow the actors to go
through the Journey the same Journey
going through the same
emotions the fear the the the the hungry
because they went through a street diet
the cold because we shot in real
locations in order to allowed the
audience to leave the journey with them
speaking of performances Enzo uh it's a
beautiful performance first of all
[Applause]
yes I'm curious what you knew about this
story coming into the project and I know
you also got a chance to speak with some
survivors um and how that perhaps
informed the way you you came into the
film
in
I'm from Uruguay and this is a very
well-known story ever since you were a
child in urug so when I was 12 years old
a Survivor came to tell his story to my
school and nobody was paying attention
until he started speaking and then it
was complete silence hearing him talk
and that's what made me realize that
that was a real story that had happened
to real people so once I found out about
this project I was just amazed and I
wanted to be part of it and this it and
so when you get the chance to actually
meet the survivors you see a little you
see a lot more of the story and you also
feel the responsibility while you're
filming because you realize that they're
going to see it that other people will
see it and you do feel that
can you talk about the conditions of the
shoot I think for everyone watching we
we really see a transformation in the
actors uh that's that feels very
authentic to what the survivors went
through the truth takes you elsewhere as
an actor because with acting sometimes
you start constructing a character it's
an artificial process and then you find
the character but this was a real story
and we live through real conditions so
we felt cold up to the point that we
wouldn't even feel our feet we felt
hunger and every day of the shoot we
felt that and it was a four-month shoot
and those conditions first are a
distraction but at the end you get used
to them and then you become part of the
conditions and then that frees you in
your performance and also the other
connection is with the fellow actors
with uh my castmates we became friends
we became almost like a family because
we rehearsed together for a long time
and we became very close and then it
becomes like you're acting with friends
and you have somebody to talk to and
share that hunger and those conditions
so all these uh conditions being so real
it just helps Michael I thought of the
music because what I I love about it is
that there's this balance between the
stakes right and the music conveying the
stakes of the film with the the subtlety
of letting the story come through can
you talk about striking that balance
through your work in order for me to
write truthful music for something I
want to always put myself in the place
of the the characters that I'm working
for um on every film and I'm always very
vocal about that I want to feel what
they're feeling I want to go through
understand what they're going through
that's fine if you're scoring Star Trek
uh or Spider-Man or something like that
uh this was an entirely different uh
thing that I was not prepared for and uh
and every day I I did I same process I
always do but it affected me in such a
different way this time and I really
even from my vantage point from me
sitting there at the piano I wanted to
make sure every single note that I wrote
was honest was truthful did not step on
what the actors were doing the story
they were portraying getting to meet the
survivors afterwards and getting to talk
and spend time with them you know that
was something I wasn't prepared for
after meeting them I realized oh they're
carrying this Joy within them you know
and they're take it and they spread it
everywhere they can and it was a freeing
and just a lovely thing to understand
and to realize in the end so it was this
a strange healing experience throughout
the entire process for myself again not
expecting it to be this sort of a thing
but um that's a testament to this
gentleman down here he he approaches
everything with his heart and that's
that's what's wonderful about it Pedro
I'm I'm curious about how you found
shooting in the elements and and you
have some of these shots where you just
have this enormous sense of scale and
and really what these people were up
against how did you go about conveying
that through your work we were very much
in service of the actors right but um
the the other big actor was the elements
it was these big mountains that were
trapping us right and um and it was this
big wall that you it it didn't allow you
to um think Beyond right it was like it
was super um oppressive and then it had
all the difficult things of shooting in
the snow you know it was really
difficult to get out to our location it
was really difficult to to get all the
stuff we needed but at the same time we
needed to be ready and we needed to be
expressive with the camera we wanted to
say something with what we were uh
showing right Beyond you know the words
or Beyond you know the the actions
themselves it needed to you know Elevate
in a way this this thing and it happened
naturally just because we were there and
we made the effort of doing it Oriel in
terms of the snowscape that this film is
working with what what was it like to
work with snow in terms of the sound
because it really does inform a lot of
the way we we understand the the Peril
that these characters are in you know
when he went the first time at the bar
of the tears he right away went he came
back and he had signal we called me and
he said listen I'm just so overwhelmed
about uh the sil of the the the mountain
no and and then we did like interviews
with with people has has spend time in
the Alpine areas and and how they
connect with the inner self in in in
this silence no so this was a clue to
find like this kind of like spiritual
way uh for the film so we use silence
not like a just like a formal way uh we
in a organic way we see the the the
silence will be like this way of uh
putting um the the characters connecting
with the with the with their own
emotions and giving like the film this
deepness no and Bion and I thought that
this this this this way is it was a
really good way to to approach uh the
movie in some ways and in in the middle
of the Stillness we have this alien
element that the skeleton of the plane
that is the shelter of them so I use
that Feliz as a way that there almost
another character in the movie so it
kind of reacts of the emotion of the of
the character so so the fuselage will
make like different kinds of sound
emphasizing the energy of of its scene
speaking of the plane Felix uh we open
this film essentially on a very
realistic um depiction of this plane
crash so from your end and the visual
effects end like what what did that work
look like in creating that for several
movies beginning with with impossible he
want always to be with the with the
actors he wants always to to be really
very realistic and very direct something
that is is true in in that way H we try
ER to first to create one we create a
couple of Gimbal and this type of stuff
in order that the the the actors ER F
all all the forces all the all the all
the dynamic no of this of this of this
element and the other sh that are you
know full C and you know are the the
normal the normal way of we we create
one one model of the of the inter Valley
we we made a thousand of photograph of
photographers of in the Valley of the of
the teers and we in in fact you know the
the accident was was a minimum part of
the effects of the of the movie we we
have done more than 1,000 shots and the
accident more or less 80 shots of of of
visual effects thank you all so much
thank you all for coming tonight thank
you
that